quality is important to me because I
think that we all have two jobs the care
that we give and improving the systems
in which we work
that's our professional responsibilities
I started my career as a nurse but even
before that I'm the oldest of nine
children a big Irish family and when the
first nephew was born to my sister you
can imagine what this Irish family was
like we were all responsible together to
take care of this this wonderful little
kid Robbie when Robbie was 2 months old
he went to his doctor had his first
checkup and the doctor told my sister
that he was great he was developing
normally everything was fine at the end
of the visit he gave him his CPT
vaccinations when my sister got Robbie
home he started to become ill she
brought him right back to the office and
he ended up in the intensive care unit
for about a week he eventually got
better and the whole family came
together to make sure that he was safe
when he went in for his four month
checkup the doctor said he was perfect
he was developing normally and at the
end of the visit he said to my sister
I'm going to give him his d PT
vaccination and my sister said don't you
remember what happened the last time he
paused for a moment
and then my sister recounted what
happened and he said that had nothing to
do with it but then he paused and he
said I'll give him half a dose and he
gave him half a dose and Robbie died
within 24 hours
when you think about the story of your
nephew do you think that's an anomaly do
you think that it's sort of a rare thing
do you feel like these are it was
indicative of a much broader problem or
do you think this really was kind of an
unusual case that got you thinking about
well it is not rare
perhaps that particular circumstance but
the fact that patients are harmed by
their care instead of helped by their
carers is unfortunately all too common
so my sister asked me three questions
that changed my whole outlook on my
career as a nurse the first thing she
said is why do you keep records separate
why are the hospital records separate
from the doctor's office record the
second question she said is why did he
not know that that wasn't the right
thing to do and then the third thing she
said why didn't he listen to me and
those three questions really changed my
outlook on what we need to improve in
quality in health care and how we need
to go about it in some cases it's a
failure of information an example one of
our staff here was taking his father
home from one of the hospitals here in
Boston after having an aneurysm in his
brain repaired and as the nurse was
preparing to discharge his father my
staff member went and said to the nurse
do you know what his situation is when
he gets home the staff members mother is
totally incapacitated and his father was
her carer and the nurse had no idea now
you might not think that that time but I
do think it is to send a patient home to
a circumstance without complete
understanding is harm patients
developing pressure ulcers in the
hospital is harm ventilated pneumonias
are eliminated all now and so I think
these all represent a professional
challenges to us because we do know how
to eliminate these so what's the what's
the challenge I mean why does this
happen why do these harms occur what's
underlying it well I'd say two things
one is in our professional education
we're taught how to care
how to fix things we're not how to
improve several years ago here at IHI we
were trying to get improvement built
into the curriculum for medical schools
in nursing schools healthcare
administration programs we found it very
hard to get people to integrate that
curriculum and to teach Krauss
professionally the second problem is we
work in broken system and in our
educational processes we're taught to be
heroes we're taught to fix it for the
individual not to fix the process in the
system so two things I think we need to
build improvement capability the science
of improvement into every curriculum
into every professional program and then
we have to be able to see we have to
learn that when we're in a situation not
to fix but to see and once we see the
system we can make it better for all
those are great
two great points and certainly as a
clinician the notion of improvement as a
part of my job is not something I spend
a lot of time thinking about and I
suspect most clinicians not not very
much time and then the second notion
that you bring up right very much we
think about fixing it for individual
patients because that's our job but
never sort of taking the step back and
saying how do we fix this not just for
my patient in front of me but the
patient I might have a month from now or
your patient that I will never see